[Music]
now just like we've been reporting
tonight after night the biden agenda is
failing and it is taking more americans
out of the labor force it's harming
businesses it is putting the country on
the path to more entitlements more
government dependency and more inflation
now at a 39-year high now someone who
knows the value of hard work as well as
anyone the host of the
by the way new show dirty jobs premieres
january 2nd and that's not all he even
has a new music video with john rich
called santa got a dirty job take a look
through wind and rain and blinding snow
santa claus never slows down he's gotta
keep on pushing them
24 hours straight
gotta out run and pick our dogs gotta do
whatever it takes don't you
all right joining us now the one and
only micro you know why are you picking
on santa claus like that what's up with
that
are you kidding me
he's my hero man santa claus is you know
he's going down chimneys reindeer
kicking mud up in his face he works all
night long you know you got to give the
guy a break we wrote a song
just no because we felt like it and we
had time and we wanted to raise some
money for our foundations and last week
it was the number one downloaded song in
the world so
you know
as i go over this and i'm looking at it
maybe it's just the way i was raised and
maybe it's why i like the two shows you
you're the only person that worked on
shows that i would like to do except for
my own shows i like doing my own shows
and that is the dirty job show that you
did which is phenomenal i don't know how
you did some of those jobs and the other
one you know is deadliest catch i love
that show and i i can watch it for hours
on end
and the reality is if you have to get up
in the morning mike and you have nothing
to do
i don't think i can think of anything
worse
than not working
correct yeah look man that's
we have a problem in the country and and
honestly in my view it's it's not really
a political problem it's a it's a human
problem you give the average person i
don't care if he's a republican or a
democrat the average person a chance to
work and make 700 bucks a week or not
work and make 700 bucks a week well most
people are going to take the easy way
that's it's just the way we're wired and
so
when you talk about these policies and
when you talk about incentivizing the
kind of behavior that we want to
encourage and disincentivizing the kind
of behavior that we want to discourage
it seems like a fairly sensible thing to
do
but but the truth is you can't mandate
work ethic you can't just
wave a magic wand at somebody and say
their
character or delayed gratification or a
decent attitude or personal
responsibility
those things have to be taught their
choices my foundation works hard to make
a persuasive case for those choices
but you're right some policies get in
the way some policies don't it's
interesting to see how that all plays
out though
what is the worst when you did the
dirtiest jobs what was the worst of the
worst
well there were 300 of them you know
there are a couple coming up this season
that are right up there but i i think
getting a ruptured lift pump out of a
wastewater treatment plant
you know i mean it's a
it's a four ton motor and a five-storey
silo and when it ruptures you kind of
got a dog paddle through the filth and
then they
they winch the whole thing out sean all
right with a big crane and when that
lift pump breaks the seal of crap that
have been holding it to the floor that
sound
that'll haunt your dreams i i watched
you and one i watched you in one episode
and i couldn't do this job because you
crawl in this little crawl space i had
to crawl all the way in and then you're
scooping out like hunks of grease and
grime and muck and you got to do it all
day i could not have done that job uh
but you did we have 20 seconds hey look
man
you're sitting there every day doing
your job we all sh we all show up
whether you're santa claus or a
newscaster or a guy on tv it doesn't
matter you know some people show up
early some people stay late those are
the people we celebrate
you know what that's right i don't know
anyone that works in any hour a day
nobody all right thanks mike crow more
hannity right after this stay with us